Wendy is in Houston Texas
hey Wendy how are you I'm doing great
thank you so much for everything that
you do and teach and for taking my call
I'm so excited no troubles how can I
help so I have a question we my husband
around baby steps too but I'm
considering kind of breaking the rules
and going out of order but I think it
actually makes sense in our case we've
been married about 13 years we have
three kids we live in a house that we
owe about 91 thousand on still and it's
worth a fair amount more than that and
the only debt that we have left is a
student loan that we acquired when after
15 years of being an elementary school
teacher I decided I wanted to be a
doctor so I did the very normal thing
and took out student loans and we did
that for nine years made it through and
finished graduate med school in 2014 and
the finished residency last July in 2017
by the time we came out or by Hakeem at
a residency we had about 230,000 in the
student loans at 6% so we've been paying
those off with somewhat gazelle-like
intensity not quite all the way their
thing was off at this point today
they're at a hundred and sixty eight
thousand and so I'm paying that off but
I met with my CPA and he is recommending
that we max out our step contributions
and he is saying that if we put 61
thousand into the step this year that
will actually decrease our taxable
income enough that we get a $21,000 tax
tables mm-hmm what's your household
income my gross so far this year is
three hundred sixteen thousand I'm a
1099 employee and this is my actual
first year from January to December
where I'm working as an ER doctor and so
I don't you know it's a little odd
because I get they just tell you for you
to do anything other than take one
hundred and sixty eight thousand in the
coming 12 months and pay that debt off
is asinine
your CPA ought to have his butt kicked
up around his neck that's asinine you
make $300,000 a year you used to make
nothing
and you have a hundred and sixty-eight
thousand and you've been messing around
with and playing around with it is time
to get out of debt Wendy you're gonna
keep us around like it's a pet if you
keep listening to this guy because he's
normalized dead in his mind and he's got
it in his head that you need to play all
these tax games you need to get out of
debt and then take all that money that
you're making and go become wealthy then
you can start putting stuff in SEPs and
no you don't do this out of order you
need to smack this debt in the mouth and
you need to keep your lifestyle down and
keep your investments as a zero and get
this debt cleaned up it's huge huge dad
yeah we've got it on film and don't have
anything else as far as the paid for and
all my friends are buying fancy cars
call the wambulance square feet and you
make 300 grand
clean up your mess and then don't act
like you make 300 grand but right now
you're a broke doctor you do what you
want to kiddo but you caught me if I
woke up in your shoes I'd do that in a
heartbeat oh there's no way you know you
have not applied the intensity you self
said that and I'm saying 168 out of 300
you ought to be able to pull this off I
mean really and you know then worry
about moving up in house and then worry
about your investing no do your baby
steps in order because there's a reason
it lays a foundation in your life for
you to be able to win for the next 10
years it might what you're describing
might be smart on for the next eight
months but not for the next eight years
it's not and you're setting yourself on
a path to justify and rationalize to
keeping this around has you've been
doing that it's time to stop this is the
Dave Ramsey show